est en train de tomber non notre
entreprise morel ils ont entre 12 et 14
ans ces jeunes participent tous les
mercredis à cet atelier d'improvisation
théâtrale à tra ici on va apprendre à
s'améliorer au mal d'informations on va
prendre soin des techniques et puis
c'est là aussi que les jeunes c'est dans
cet espace là moment là qu'ils vont
pouvoir tenter de nouvelles choses des
nouveaux personnages objectif pour eux
être à l'aise à l'oral et apprendre à
mieux s'exprimer et à s'affirmer pour
ces jeunes c'est aussi un lien d'amitié
qui se crée j'ai commencé ce appareil
vers la 6e et ça m'a tout de suite plu
parce qu'en fait avant j'étais très
timide et où est justement grâce à
l'impro et bassam a aidé plus m'ouvrir
aux autres et à pouvoir parler en public
sans être stressé et tous ses biens en
être avec le public parce que moi ça me
fait plaisir quand j'arrive à faire rire
les gens donc je viens pas forcément
pour le public mais je viens surtout
pour m'amuser on est tout le temps là
pour apprendre pour aller vers le
positif il nous montre vers le haut mais
il nous descendent jamais ces ateliers
sont animés par des comédiens issus de
déclic théâtre comme alexandra elle a
commencé l'impro à l'adolescence après
avoir obtenu une place dans la compagnie
elle mène maintenant des ateliers et les
valeurs qu'on m'a appris d'improvisation
je trouve ça très important mais et si
on peut les transmettre et ça passe par
l'apprentissage donc cessé à gauche trop
important de 9 à 18 ans les enfants
apprennent donc tout et techniques de
l'improvisation jusqu'à en faire
peut-être pour certains leur métier